le revenu de base ce minimum social
garanti pour une partie de la population
semble être une nouveauté politique
l'écouté ça qu aucune action ne pourra
être valablement menées au profit de ces
familles si elle ne comporte la garantie
d'un minimum de ressources sans lequel
il n'aurait pu ne leur est pas possible
de vivre dans la dignité
à besançon dès 1968 un minimum social
garanti est distribuée aux personnes
âgées
dès 1974 aux femmes seules et en 1975 à
toute la population pauvre de la ville
fin des années 70 belfort lance la même
initiative sociale car à l'époque pas de
rsa mais juste des banques pour se
chauffer ou pour la soupe populaire
alors très vite se pose la question de
l'assistanat qu'entraînerait ce revenu
minimum
distribué par la mairie est ce que vous
n'avez pas l'impression à travers cela
de contribuer à faire des bisontins des
personnes davantage insisté non je ne
pense pas parce que nous avons supprimé
a besoin sont toutes les aides qui était
donné sous la forme de bons chauffage
nourriture vêtements et nous donnons aux
personnes les moyens pour elle-même
choisir ce parmi leurs besoins dans les
années 80 la france est confrontée à une
montée de la pauvreté démunis face à
cette misère
d'autres municipalités imite belfort et
besançon nîmes par exemple mettre en
place elle aussi un revenu minimum
certes dans toutes les villes de notre
pays des secours de tous genres sont
dispensés coup plus démunis mais le plan
de lutte contre la misère peu vient de
mettre en place la municipalité de nîmes
en complétant les différentes îles zen
social quant aux petits de deux mille
six cent cinquante ans mensuel constitue
une initiative d'avant garde qui fait de
nîmes une ville pilote dans le domaine
social
quelques années plus tard c'est la ville
de grenoble qui met en place ce minimum
social garanti une collectivité son
coeur n'est pas une collectivité
et si on doit aller chez quelqu'un sur
le bord de la route ce n'est pas la
peine d'améliorer la gestion et de
préparer l'avenir
à la fin des années 80 le revenu minimum
garanti se généralise en france face à
l'augmentation des chômeurs en fin de
droits mais le concept évolue
l'ille-et-vilaine par exemple met en
place un contrat pour obliger le
bénéficiaire à faire une formation c'est
l'aspect contrepartie du revenu minimum
s'engager à suivre une formation ou à
participer à des travaux d'intérêts
collectifs
on attend des bénéficiaires un effort de
réinsertion c'est grâce à ces
expérimentations locales que le rmi sera
mise en place au niveau national en 1981
en 2019 des députés veulent tester une
nouvelle forme de revenu de base dans
plusieurs départements
[Musique]